dude michael caine's in everything i
literally could have picked a movie and
it would have been I mean he's in
everything dude
I mean he's even in Dunkirk as an
uncredited voice like are you
kidding me I gotta pay in Dunkirk is
there a movie coming out worse Michael
Caine impression of all time Fonda
whatever or over that director
that I walked if we're out the
Dark Knight for there if there's a spot
I could fit in there so bad uh who
Michael Caine has a website that's
hilarious you know he literally had
nothing to do with it Michael Caine has
a website Wow
the official website of Sir Michael
Caine first of all if you're a sir dude
if I I'll never become a sir but if
anyone ever anointed me and I
became a sir and anyone ever called me
sir Chris D'Elia I'd say hey man
just call me Chris okay
dude look at all the movies he's been in
this guy you know he doesn't give a
about any of them - especially the later
ones so funny dude like he was in now
you see me too you know and they're like
they were like hey Michael Caine as
agents were like do you
well you feel like they want you to do
all do it
no well this is the I'll do it
okay all right they want you to fly to
Aldo it I don't care though I I'll do
any movie you ever want me today okay
Zach Braff's doing it and directing a
movie called going against Aldo it hos
AK Braff I'll do it
he was in scrubs walk scrubs I'll do it
scrubs our show on NBC was a big hit
Warsame bc i was it was on TV
watch TV I'll do it
they'll give you 19 million dollars
I'll down care I'll do it okay
hey they're doing a movie called the
Kingsmen although it would you want to
hear what it's about and I they want to
fly you to ball do it hey hey they want
hey they want you to be an interstellar
obviously I'll do it I feel like in
scripts it just says Michael Caine it
doesn't even and then they and then they
shoot it and then when they're shooting
it they're like let's have his name be
Harry Brown
let's have his name be Hobbs I
mean I just I turned on the
prestige the other day he's just he's in
that obviously imagine having a movie
called the prestige and Michael
Caine's not in it it's called the
prestige all our agents yeah there's a
movie of our code the prestige what a
bloody LM or not in it oh well
we'll get old do it yeah yeah okay just
tell him I'll do it well there's not a
part for a guy your age
Roy ed in okay Hildy the guy said he'll
write it in no I'm Michael Caine I
mean
has honestly Michael Caine for real said
like at this point how much has he
honestly said what see internet how much
is he honestly said that really
I bet he said it seven times and I'm
talking about when it first came out or
whatever and it was this internet and
then they were like oh it's like
connected a bunch of connected computers
and it's like a network and and you can
share that like communication and
knowledge and all that all right
and then like a week later he was like
yeah you're about the scene in that
thing what is it again and then that was
the second time and then they were like
oh it's the thing where the computers
are and so oh right right yeah yeah well
I they set me up with an and and an a
lol account and he's like no it's a o el
Roy Roy Roy and then somebody and then
like three days later would he heard
about a AOL and he was like oh is that
that thing that's a lot of computers and
they're like what and then like what was
it cold and he's like the the Internet
and he's like yeah yeah what he's that
and then he's like oh yeah it's like the
computers and then like so he kind of
knew what it was but then like a few
years later he just stopped
using it you know cuz it was like 93 and
he was like just doing mr.
destiny and noises off and the
movie blue ice and the Muppet Christmas
Carol and and and and and then
and then he did them in and then
and then and they forgot and then
someone was like I'll email it to you
and he was like what he's died they were
like what's what they're like an email
and they was like oh it's like I don't
you have an AOL and he's like oh yeah I
got a lol and they're like no it's a oh
and he's like what would that code that
and they're like you mean the internet
he's I
he's da and that was like the fourth
time or third or fourth time and then it
just happened a few like a few years
after that and then like the last time
he did it was like in 2011 was like the
seventh time somebody was like you know
you should get a web site I mean I know
you have like a great career everything
but like you know them you know it'd be
cool like Gnomeo and Juliet is coming
out and you're obviously a voice in that
because they would never make that movie
without you doing the voice because
there's somebody called Lord redbrick in
it so you know and you said you'll do it
so before Cars 2 goes
into production because you're obviously
going to play Finn McMissile again you
should probably get a website Oh
it's a you know a homepage that
you could have on the internet nice oh
oh I swear the gods
that happened seven times
whatever helps you know and then they
were like yeah well you can have things
on there like you know you can have my
Michael Caine news that people will go
to and by this time is like way too late
for it a website anyway
because like everyone has Instagram
like that and go back up go back up and
you have all the home for all your
and you know you have like you
go to the website it'd be Michael Caine
calm and then you have the Michael Caine
news and you have Michael Caine you have
like a buyer
about you they don't have a place to go
for a filmography even though nobody
will check it because I am DB exists and
then we'll have like a place where you
can brag about like your achievements
and so-called unlock bragging and like
no you don't actually have to do it
we'll do it and then you know we'll have
like your your timeline and then
it'll be cool because we'll be able to
put your books on there which nobody
even knows that you have but you have
obviously because you're 90
years old and you definitely wrote some
books because you're too famous because
people who are 90 years old
and that famous obviously have written
books and then also we'll put up a
gallery and we'll put your favorite
pictures on there and he says all right
and then and if you go to Michael
Caine's gallery it's got and one is of
course of him in black and white because
he's been alive since cameras existed
I'll put two okay Michael can you send
us your favorite pictures I'll do it
can you send us your favorite pic all
too well have two favorite pictures oh
cool can you email it to us all sigh
nevermind just I'll come over and get
them and scan them what scan and nothing
it's fine you can get it through the
internet oh I'm not gonna ask for a days
but I think I think I know where he is
because that was the seventh time that
was the last time you did it
ah a gallery dude how funny is it
when somebody has a gallery on their
website and it has two pictures I mean
one picture is a fear and then it's got
different faces of him like throughout
the years but not really though it's
kind of only like well I guess one is in
his 20s and ones maybe now
now-ish but then while the other ones is
of him get his haircut like what is that
is still from a movie I guess right has
to be oh god who put this
website together dude Ray
Charles Finn McMissile that's like so
offensive you know yeah we'll get
Michael Caine to do it obviously
why that's Finn McMissile what is that
what couldn't be found
oh great Michael Caine has a
thing on the bottom of his website
website that says useful links and you
click on it and it says sorry this page
could not be found
I'm sweating I'm laughing so hard
oh that that is the hardest I've
left on the website are on the podcast
website oh my god oh my god
I mean the movies this guy's been in and
the movie the the movies that sound like
movies he would be in are unbelievable
the quiet american course Michael Caine
would be in that the actors of course
Michael Caine would be in that second
second second hand Lions course he'd be
in that freedom a history of us of
course he'd be in that I mean do it my
producer is surfing around on this guy's
website Michael Caine's wefts website
and it literally I mean what the
how is that the quote okay so Michael
Caine is called the elephant to
Hollywood by the way did he write this
book maybe
whatever it's a book about him it's an
autobiography so he did all right the
quote that's you know I like there's a
quote that's like the best book I've
ever read or like one of the top
autobiographies of this generation the
quote that they're Pro mowing this book
to get you to want to read it
I you're not on the on the website
is and I quote a very British star a
very British star what the is that
his name oh my god his real name is mmm
well okay I mean his real name is more
British than Finn McMissile and
Lord and whatever it was you
could his real name is so British you
could put Lord in front of it and it
would make it less British his name
could be London Manchester and
it would be less British than this this
is his real name Maurice Mikkel
white it's been a long journey for
Maurice Nicoll white born with rickets
and London's poverty-stricken Elephant &
Castle to the bright lights of Hollywood
the most British sentence of all time
rickets
you know rickets in London's poverty
stricken Elephant & Castle what is it
what is it oh my god dude and the
picture of him on this photo of him
pointing Michael Caine the Elephant
Hollywood the autobiography and the
picture of him why would you if your
Michael Caine why would you write a book
I mean I understand people might want to
read it
but why do you give a I don't
understand I don't understand a very
British star it's the thing that they
have in quotes what was that is that
another book down there he wrote another
book he wrote he wrote two
autobiographies hey man wait till later
and to write only one and also this is
the most British quote they're trying to
present charm and humor of natural
recontour and guess if humor has au in
it Maurice Michael white you bet
look at how they try to make it another
one - come on dude it's non
autobiography thank God is the other
more there's not more guys got three
books okay I mean give us a these
guys who write books it's like it
doesn't I don't understand
you make what a million dollars what
this guy's got to have 35 houses
I mean what's he worth oh cool he's
worth 75 million dollars cool hey you
were 75 million dollars
don't write a book the dude if I'm
worth 75 million no how much of that is
his book three hundred and sixty
thousand dollars guarantee it if that if
that